gut
hallo herzlich willkommen in meine torte
nennt heute gibt es ein kleines video
das heißt ich zeige euch zuerst ein
grundrezept für salzigen hefeteig und
danach mache ich da raus bitte bei den
zutaten müsst ihr noch drauf achten
ich sag jetzt eben video nicht genau die
genauen mengenangaben sondern die
schreibe ich euch auf meinem blog auf
und zwar deshalb weil ich heute eine
größere menge herstellen und ich glaube
es wird euch nur verwirren wenn ihr die
kiloweise mail und fleisch und heute
benutzen müssen deswegen schaut einfach
mein block vorbei da seht ihr die
zutaten darunter gerechnet für 24 und
ich denke für sechs personen und mit
denen könnt ihr dann nach dem video die
ableitung machen und zuerst zeige ich
euch jetzt über den hefeteig herstellt
wie eben schon gesagt schaut ihr wegen
den genauen mengenangaben am besten auf
meinem blog vorbei und an zutaten
braucht ihr mehl salz hefe und fett ich
nehme jetzt öl und dann braucht ihr noch
eine flüssigkeit
da ich jetzt heute peter draus machen
werde benutze ich halb halb wasser und
milch ihr könnt aber auch nur mäßig
nehmen falls ihr ein weiches gepäck
haben möchtet oder bei pizzateig
verwende ich zum beispiel nur wasser aus
den zutaten wie macht ihr einen hefeteig
dazu gebt ihr das mehl in eine schüssel
das könnt ihr natürlich auch mit dem
thermomix machen oder auch einfach per
hand kneten
je nachdem wie ihr das machen wollten
und die möglichkeit gehabt da kommst du
pfalz mit sonntag gebe ich jetzt eine
mulde rein und dann nehme ich mir das
wasser oder aus die hefe und lösten hefe
mit dem warmen wasser auf
und dann haben dass hilfe gemisch hierzu
mehrere und stark gibt ja auch noch das
restliche die restliche flüssigkeit mit
rein immer an fall eben die milch und
dann was die maschine kurz laufen und
dann könnt ihr auch das fett mit
dazugeben und den hefeteig schön kneten
lassen
wenn ihr dann einen schönen garten
hefeteig habt nehmt ihr den ausschüssen
heraus und geht einfach mal durch und
dann formte ihn zu einer kugel immer von
außen nach innen den kompletten teig
dann einmal umdrehen und stehen gebt ihr
dann in einer großen schüssel decken mit
einem tuch ab und lasst ihn für etwa
eine halbe stunde bis 1 stunde einen
warmen ort gehen aus diesem hefeteig
könnt ihr zum beispiel auch pizza
herstellen wenn ihr baby speck last und
sie durch wasser ersetzt oder das ist
auch der teig wie flammkuchen und
eigentlich alles als gebäcke die es so
gibt und den teig last jetzt einfach so
lange gehen wie ihr die füllung
vorbereitet und dann können auch schon
verwenden und als füllung habe ich mit
zwei varianten ausgedacht einmal die
typische hackfleisch füllung und einmal
eine füllung mit feta um spinat und die
zutaten dazu lässt sich euch dann wieder
in meinem blog auf und ihr seht sie
jetzt einmal zusammengefasst
für die fleisch füllung braucht ihr
hackfleisch ich habe hier rein ist
hinter hackfleisch ihr könnt aber auch
gemischtes hackfleisch nehmen mit rind
und lamm
dann habe ich tomaten aus der dose im
sommer könnt ihr auch aromatische
frische tomaten nehmen aber im winter
finde es besser wenn man die auslöser
benutzt dann braucht der petersilie ein
paar paprika hier noch eine scharfe
spitz paprika zwiebeln tomatenmark und
paprika mark und gewürze wie salz und
pfeffer etwas cayennepfeffer oder
paprikapulver und oregano und
präferenzen die zwiebeln und das
restliche gemüse sollten fein gewürfelt
werden und es sollte es das auch nicht
in den mixer machen denn damit alles
viel zu flüssig und der geschmack wird
etwas verworren wenn ihr zwiebel und
schält solltet ihr darauf achten diese
wurzel möglichst dran zu lassen
also hier ganz knapp nur abschneiden und
den rest unter schälen
denn später beim würfeln wird die wurzel
die zwiebel zusammenhalten
nicht auseinanderfällt und dieses ende
könnt ihr aber wegschneiden dann könnt
ihr die zwiebel halbieren und zum
schneiden solltet ihr immer ein sehr
scharfes messer benutzen ansonsten
drückt ihr viel zu viel saft von der
zwiebel heraus und dann brennt auch
richtig in den augen und dann hier vorne
auch nicht bis zur wurzel schneiden
sondern ein stück zurück dann bleibt ich
zwiebel zusammen und fällt beim
schneiden nicht auseinander und ihr
könnt sie dann in ruhe werfen
beim letzten stück umklappen und zwiebel
zu ende würfeln 7 können die dann schon
mal in eure schüssel geben und auch da
kann schon können schon die tomaten mit
dazu und auch das hat
dann schneidet ihr noch die paprika in
kleine stücke dazu entfernt ihr vorher
aber dass das kerngehäuse und auch hier
die weiße haut
und dann zuerst in meine streit und dann
die streifen
zum schluss kommt noch die petersilie
mit dazu die aus der macht ihr so einem
bündel dann könntet ihr darum der
packung
da wird alles noch miteinander vermischt
am besten geht natürlich mit der am
schnellsten auf
für diese füllung braucht ihr spinat
ich nehme da am liebsten tiefgekühlten
spinat weil der frische immer weiß
einfach nicht wie frisch noch der
frische spinat ist und hier wisst ihr
einfach da wird direkt nach der ernte
tiefgefroren
dann braucht ihr etwas väter und
zwiebeln die habe ich jetzt schon gehabt
damit schneller geht und dann gewürze
wie pfeffer oregano pfefferminze und für
die schärfe etwas cayennepfeffer salzen
würde ich die füllung nicht der käse
einen sehr hohen zeit gehalten
den spinat lass dir da etwas aufbauen
und zerrupft in ein wenig und stark
kommt jetzt der väter mit dazu den sap
legte er einfach so erreichen einfach
mit den händen
ich fühle dass jetzt einmal um weil die
schüssel zu klein war
da kommen dann die zwiebel noch mit rein
und die gewürze dann vermischt ihr alles
anhören hefeteig und steckte ihn auch
die arbeitsfläche und stand teilt ihr
den informationen also ich habe heute
eine große menge ich mach 16 titel aber
die genaue angaben wie viele portionen
ihr machen sollt stehen noch auf meinem
blog und die portionen haben dann
eigentlich etwas mehr als 100 gramm
die nehmt ihr euch dann und macht sowie
freuen beim großen tag einfach immer von
außen in die mitte dann umdrehen und
umformen
wenn das gut formen zwischen den händen
nicht klappt dann nehmt euch die teilung
und formt sie auf der arbeitslose und
wenn ihr das ganze weit haben und alle
kugeln gerollt habt nehmt ihr euch eine
strikte etwas flach und dann wird sie in
die länge ausgeräumt und da bereitet ihr
euch am besten schon euer bahnverkehr
und platziert den teig dann drauf und da
kommt jetzt die füllung drauf ich war
nicht meine daten flash füllung an und
es sind so immer gut zwei esslöffel das
wird dann hier einfach drauf gemacht
nicht ganz bis zum rand und stand lag
ihr jeden seiten an
auch nicht ganz zur mitte und dann
schlagt ihr hier
die eine seite über die andere und
trennt sich
und wenn es da habt nehmt ihr euch das
nicht mehr weiter aufgehen ihr könnt sie
direkt packen
ich habs jetzt bei 200 grad etwa 20 bis
25 minuten gebacken
frisch aus dem ofen sehen die peters so
aus die fertigen schiff jedem staat ihr
am besten mit einem salat dazu passt
ganz gut ein grüner salat oder ein
gemischter salat mit einer zitrone essig
marinade und ihr könnt die schiffchen
auch kalt servieren oder am nächsten tag
auf dem fressen ihr müsst ihr nicht
unbedingt aufwärmen
man kann die fertigen schief gehen auch
ganz gut einfrieren und danach wieder
auftauen
dazu einfach ein paar minuten wieder in
den ofen schieben und das war es
eigentlich schon für heute ich wünsche
euch viel spaß beim nachbacken und freue
mich aufs nächste mal da geht es nämlich
dann ein weiteres türkisches rezept und
zwar dass christus video und bis eine
schöne zeit und bis dahin tschüss